we're not just fighting an epidemic
we're fighting a nympho demmick what
he's talking about is the rapid global
spread of false information during my
research I came across three types of
fake news and misinformation regarding
the corona virus number one was wrong
health advice which was to be honest
sometimes pretty weird for a moment
there was a belief that eating garlic
would be able to get rid of the virus
people started to say that you should
start taking into a drinking lukewarm
order and and that's gonna help you kill
the virus so they prescribed a
homeopathic drug or prophylactic effect
and that was completely false
information
number two was false information about
the origin or the spread of the virus
and the latest debate was that's
regarding m5g and how 5g connects with
the corona virus so that the Europeans
brought it into the country and that it
was not going to affect anyone other
than why people at first and the third
one was general false rumors about the
severity of the crisis so many of these
are real photos or videos but they taken
completely out of context this video
claims to be taken in the u.s. this year
but it's actually a looting in Mexico in
2017 some of them are just so outlandish
but in this corner crisis situation it's
sometimes really hard to distinguish
between something that's true and
something that's false so how can we
detect and stop the spread of fake news
and misinformation a former CIA analyst
and a fact checker from BuzzFeed will
tell us
what we know about missing
disinformation is that it works because
panic anxiety fear anger and it really
plays on people's instincts to pass it
on
you know immediate worried anxiety we're
sort of in a situation where our brains
often sort of shut off that critical
thinking part that makes us stock when
we see information instead of having
that instinct of I have to tell
everybody in my life what I just learned
say okay maybe instead I can search it
up and see if there is correct
information available misinformation
means it's accidentally wrong
information this information on fake
news means it's intentionally wrong
information meant to manipulate those
can be found on social media or on fake
news sites or passed on via group chat
by family or friends just simply ask
questions of your friends where did you
get it and then you'll start to see you
know that person got it from someone
else who probably got it from somebody
else who probably for you know got it
from somebody else he'll quickly realize
okay that's a rumor that's not
necessarily accurate information a lot
of the time you get a sort of authority
referenced in theirs before passing any
of that on just go to the website of the
authority itself and if it's not
available on their official channels you
should just take a step back and say
okay maybe this is not good health
advice what do you think about memes
hahaha that style of sharing information
that's text on an image is probably the
most hazardous way to share information
that there is and that's because there's
just absolutely no way you're getting
the full picture
you're completely lacking context you're
completely lacking sources and so I
would say that if you're seeing a meme
trying to pass on information about the
virus in any way just don't believe it
fact-checking organizations are a great
source of information they're an
unbiased third party for the most part
there's a network called the
international fact-checking network that
has accredited over a hundred fact
checkers around the world to be able to
look at these falsehoods and debunk them
in different languages in different
regions so they're few super easy online
tools you can use to detect fake news
my favorite is Google reverse image
search the person posting these pictures
claims they were taken in Italy you just
right-click on one and go to search
Google for image it already says
Venezuela bolivars on the streets and
you can see a lot of fact-checking sites
have debunked this picture done there's
so many tools but just to name two
others as examples there is a bottom
eater or the bottom eater where you can
check whether a Twitter account is a
bottle lot and then there is news guard
which is a an extension where you can
see whether a website is trustworthy or
not the best piece of advice really is
like do not insta share anything like
just take a breath
stop you know because it is that sort of
like emotional reaction that is
obviously you know it's very very
understandable that we all are feeling
these things but that's what gets us
into trouble
obviously passing on bad health advice
can have direct and dangerous
consequences but spreading other types
of wrong information about the virus can
have less immediate but broader
implications a lot of the myths of
disinformation that we see has spawned a
lot of racism and a lot of hate and
that's a global phenomenon the the exact
perfect time for a country that wants to
leverage something like high emotions
stress and a lot of sort of conflicting
information out there to push a
particular political agenda
your grandma like my grandma is telling
you to eat a lot of garlic you can say
okay yes I will but this will the way
this virus works is it can be carried
even if you have no symptoms which
garlic is not going to help but I think
being really patient and trying to
explain the facts to the best of your
ability maybe providing somebody a
fact-check saying hey this isn't
actually true might not convince
everybody but it might stop it from
spreading just a little bit more and
that's worth it which questions do you
have regarding the corona crisis please
with us now and leave a comment and if
you feel like it go check out the other
episodes of hash tag in this together
[Music]